SIERRA: Storytelling Podcast Week is starting
soon! Join us Wednesday July 21st through
Sunday July 25th for live story salons, interviews,
panels, and live episodes, including a special
live episode from us here at Why It Matters
and the Council on Foreign Relations. We re
going to talk about how the show gets made
and the behind the scenes of how we bring
our stories to you! You ll also have the opportunity
to interact with some of your favorite podcasters
across fiction and non-fiction shows including
the podcasters behind Last Day, Grammar Girl,
Welcome to Night Vale, BBC s The Comb and
more as they join us live on Podbean Live.
Register now podcastweek.live/storytelling
and use the code WHYITMATTERS - all one word
- WHYITMATTERS for a free pass! We'll see
you at Storytelling Podcast Week!
SIERRA: Fresh water is one of those things
we forget about when it s easily accessible.
But as soon as it s not there, even for a
short time, it becomes painfully clear how
much we need it. Aside from thirst, we rely
on water to cook, to bathe, to do laundry.
Behind the scenes, much larger quantities
are needed to make our clothes and grow the
food we eat. But as climate change accelerates,
water is becoming scarce in arid, highly-populated
regions all over the world. From India to
Israel, from Italy to Mexico, to Australia.
Countries of all kinds are struggling to survive
and adapt to a much drier reality. At the
heart of the problem are outdated rules and
institutions that lack the flexibility demanded
by a changing climate. If new compromises
aren t reached, the problem is going to get
a lot worse. My name is Gabrielle Sierra,
and this is Why It Matters. Today, water scarcity.
Al Jazeera News:
It s one thing you can t survive without and
yet more and more people around the world
are being forced to try.
KHON2 News: Severe drought has hit Maui once
again.
CGTN: China s Taiwan region is facing the
worst water crisis in 56 years.
PBS NewsHour: From the Rio Grande to the Rocky
Mountains a mega-drought is underway, it's
shaping up to be the worst water crisis in
generations.
SIERRA: I hear a lot of scary things about
climate change when it comes to this topic,
is the world running out of water?
POSTEL: The world is not running out of water.
But we may be changing where it is, and how
accessible it is to us.
POSTEL: I m Sandra Postel. And I am the director
of the Global Water Policy Project. And what
I try to do is sort of connect the science
and the policy and the practice around water
so we can have water security for all beings.
SIERRA: Sounds like a big job description.
POSTEL: It's pretty big. I take it in chunks.
SIERRA: The world isn t running out of water.
There is enough to meet the needs of every
human on Earth, or at least there would be
if it was evenly distributed. Water scarcity
isn t about the total amount of water, but
the fact that there isn t enough usable water
where it is needed. And in these places, climate
change is making the problem worse, fast.
POSTEL: The basic physics of it really is
that as the temperature of the planet warms,
the atmosphere expands, which means there's
more capacity for the atmosphere to hold water.
And so in a dry place, that means you're going
to have more evaporation, which is going to
dry it out further. In a wet place, you're
bringing up more water, and you're going to
get more condensation, and it's going to rain
more intensively. So as a rule of thumb, climate
change will make dry areas drier, wet areas
wetter, and the intensity of those events
is increasing.
POSTEL: I think the primary way we're going
to experience climate change, and already
are, is through the water cycle. And we're
already seeing that in the southwestern US,
we're in the midst of a mega drought. That
it seems the second worst we've seen in 1200
years. And it's something we really have to
grapple with. You know, I think we need to
also look at our language around this and
start talking in dry places about aridification
more than drought, because we're going to
see a long term chronic drying, that requires
a different response than a temporary drought
that we expect to end. There'll be more rain
in certain years than others, but the long
term trend will be a drying out of the environment,
less water available, less water in the soil.
And that's a different aspect of security
for society.
SIERRA: Water is a matter of global security
because there are a lot of human beings living
in those dry environments, whether it be Los
Angeles or Marrakesh. The UN estimates that
water scarcity currently affects 750 million
people globally, and that by 2035, half the
world s population will be living under high
water stress. Alongside the vast human suffering
it will cause, that much scarcity has the
potential to lead to migration, deep economic
problems, diplomatic faceoffs and even outright
conflict. A big part of the problem is that
the world didn t plan its cities, or its water
infrastructure, with climate change in mind.
GIORDANO: A lot of the issues that we face
on water scarcity, as well as water overabundance
or flooding are relatively recent and what
I mean by relatively recent is the last, you
know, even 50 years, 75 years.
SIERRA: This is Mark Giordano, he holds a
Chair in Environment and International Affairs
at Georgetown University s Walsh School of
Foreign Service.
GIORDANO: People didn't talk about water scarcity
in the way they do now or a global water crisis
until maybe the early 2000s or maybe late,
late 1900s. And I point that out because the
institutions we've developed to manage water
were mostly about building infrastructure
to access water and to use water, to build
dams, to build canals, to build flood control
systems. Because the questions were usually,
how can we get more water? Now we're asking
the questions of how can we manage the water
we have better because there is no more water
to keep developing.
GIORDANO: So now we're in a situation where
we've over-allocated the water, our institutions
were built for something else and now we're
trying to figure out what to do. And a big
part of it is building understanding that
users of water often don't know there are
other users of water. If you start talking
about the water around wherever you live,
you will very quickly start using, my water,
our water, their water, you ll appropriate
the water yourself. So farmers talk about
their water and cities talk about their water
and California talks about its water and Colorado
talks about its water or US talks about its
water versus Mexico s water.
GIORDANO: The number one thing to remember
is that water is a shared resource and it
doesn't belong to any one person, any one
state, any one industry. We re all in it together.
We have to make sure we all understand that
and remember that, and that if I forget that,
the negative impact on you might come back
to haunt me later. With that kind of basic
idea there, we have to think about setting
up institutions that are gonna last over time.
That means dealing with variability, thinking
through how might the world change and how
can we make sure that we can adapt through
the institutions we built, whether that be
a formula institution on paper or a social
institution, that's, that's not on paper.
SIERRA: In order to understand how climate
change will affect water, first we have to
understand the basics of how water functions
in the environment. It feels like one of those
101 things that we just never really ask about.
So, let s ask about it.
SIERRA:
So, I grew up in New York and we re actually
kind of famous for our amazing tap water.
You know, people say it s what makes the bagels
and the pizza taste good, but beyond that,
it s also just not something I ve thought
about a lot in my life. I think people just
kind of expect it to be there. So, can you
tell me just a little bit about how water
works? You know, where does it come from?
POSTEL: You know, most of the water is salt
water, just a very tiny amount, less than
two and a half percent, is freshwater. And
a lot of that two thirds of that is locked
up in glaciers and ice caps. And so we're
dealing with a very small percentage of all
the water on earth that's fresh and drinkable
and useful for all the things we need. So
having said that, that water cycles, and the
basic supply comes down as rain and snow from
condensation in the atmosphere. And so, it
falls onto the land somewhere. And then depending
on what's going on, it'll do one of three
things really, it'll run off the land and
join a creek or a stream and become what we
call runoff. And that'll eventually end up
in the sea, it can soak into the soil, and
then potentially recharge groundwater below
that, or it can evaporate or transpire back
to the atmosphere pretty quickly. So that
creates the cycle
POSTEL: And then the question is how we use
and manage the water that's in that cycle.
And the other thing that's really important,
you grew up in New York, well, every place
has its own water cycle also. Every watershed
has its own cycle, my backyard garden has
a little water cycle. So water cycles on different
timeframes and on different scales. So that
creates some interesting management challenges
as well.
POSTEL: You're going to have a very different
relationship between precipitation and evaporation
if you're in a desert, than if you're in a
tropical rainforest.
SIERRA: Water is constantly cycling and refreshing
itself according to natural laws. And this
provides a bounty for human use. But if human
beings put too much pressure on the water
cycle, especially in vulnerable regions, things
can break down. Take groundwater, which collects
under the earth s surface, filling the porous
spaces in soil, rocks, and sediments, contrary
to popular belief it is not actually a giant
pool underground. Anyway, we drill into these
spaces to access and consume this water trapped
inside. Groundwater is then replenished by
rain and snow, as it melts and seeps back
into the land. In places like California s
central valley, farmers drill deep to pump
out enormous quantities for use and irrigation.
In fact, groundwater extraction has been so
aggressive there that the entire region is
sinking, sometimes at a rate of more than
a foot per year. So the problem is that groundwater
replenishes itself very slowly. It can take
weeks, months, and even years to renew itself.
Extract too much too quickly and the source
runs dry.
POSTEL: We've gotten very good at extracting
water to meet our needs. You know, the way
we primarily do it from rivers, for example,
is to dam them up and create a reservoir,
which can then be delivering water to farmers
and to and to cities, on our own timeframe.
If we're a farmer or a city where there's
groundwater we drill a deep well and then
pump that water up from the ground. And so
we've basically developed these engineering
technologies to access that water and of course,
developed some very big infrastructure to
move the water to where it's needed. You know,
nature has given us kind of a difficult hand
when it comes to water because you need a
lot of sunshine to grow crops. But when you
have a lot of sunshine, you don't have a lot
of rain. And so we've had to move water to
where the crops are best grown. And that often
means, you know, moving water from a wet place
to a dry place.
SIERRA: What about the relationship between
agriculture and water consumption?
POSTEL: Agriculture is the biggest consumer
of water in the world. About 70% of all the
water we extract from rivers and groundwater
aquifers around the world goes to agriculture,
and much of that is consumed, you know, it
doesn't go back into the water cycle right
away. It's transpired by crops back to the
atmosphere, so we can't immediately reuse
it. So agriculture is the primary reason we
see depletion in much of the world. And I
want to say, you know, a good bit of that
is that it just takes a lot of water to grow
crops. Again, I don't want to castigate agriculture,
farmers are doing great work to provide us
with these items to eat and to make clothes
out of, but it just takes a lot of water.
SIERRA:When it comes to agriculture and water
scarcity, the most important question to ask
is where the crops are grown, rather than
how much water they consume. So, that may
sound a bit confusing, but take cocoa for
example. It consumes a lot of water, but it
s grown in tropical rainforests where there
s lot of rain. California almonds, on the
other hand, consume a lot of water in a very
dry place. From a sustainability perspective,
that is a problem. Nonetheless, as droughts
have intensified in California over the past
two decades, almond production has doubled.
Understanding the water cost for any given
product can be hard work. And most of us go
through our daily lives without understanding
just how big our water footprint is.
POSTEL: So if we're an average american, it
takes about 2000 gallons of water to sustain
our daily life, our daily lifestyle. 2000
gallons a day, only five or 10% of that is
the water we're using at home, and half of
that is in our diet. A third of it is in our
energy use. Maybe 10% is in our computers
and phones and coffee mugs and you know the
things that we use and buy. And then five
or 10% is the water we use at home, indoors
and outdoors. So, it's a lot of water.
POSTEL: And a lot of it's hiding, you know,
if you look around, everything takes water
to make. And so if we are wearing a cotton
t-shirt we're looking at, you know what, as
much as 700 gallons of water to make that
one cotton shirt. Most of that is water used
to grow the cotton out in the field. You know,
it's a good thing to recognize that one of
the simplest ways in our lives to save water
is to not waste anything.
SIERRA: Saving water is something we have
been told to do our whole lives. Whether it
is turning off the tap when you are brushing
your teeth or making sure you take care of
leaks. We re not as used to thinking about
the water that goes into our shirts. But we
have to learn how to think this way, because
increased scarcity is coming. Still, lifestyle
changes are not enough to address a problem
as large as climate-related scarcity. Only
nations, and groups of nations, have the resources
to build the new, adaptable institutions we
are going to need in our water-scarce future.
After the break, we're going to take a look
at an example that shows exactly what I mean.
Not in the western steppes of China, or the
drying fields of South Africa, but right here
at home, in the U.S.
SIERRA: I wanted to tell you about another
podcast I think you ll like: The Last Archive
from Harvard historian and New Yorker writer
Jill Lepore. This season, Lepore is investigating
purveyors of doubt hoaxers, fraudsters, pseudoscientists
and how the peddling of doubt evolved over
the 20th century, leading all the way to the
Capitol Insurrection on January 6, 2021. This
show is unlike anything you ve heard before:
history animated by long lost archival tapes
and documents, intrepid reporting, and radio
drama reenactments. The Last Archive unfurls
like a classic 1930s gumshoe mystery but takes
on the big issues of today. How do we know
what we know, and why does it seem, sometimes,
lately, as if we don t know anything at all?
Listen to The Last Archive wherever you get
your podcasts. From Pushkin Industries.
SIERRA: Ok. Example time. Close your eyes.
Imagine you re standing at the top of the
grand canyon on a hot summer day. You hear
the cry of an eagle, and the sound of tourists
munching sandwiches. Thousands of feet below,
carving its way through the canyon, is the
Colorado river. Fed by the snowmelt of the
Rockies and other Western mountains, the Colorado
is not the largest river in the United States,
but it may be the most important. It is also
the centerpiece of the country s struggle
with water scarcity. Millions of people depend
on it, and every year, it provides less water.
CBSNews: Red flag fire warnings have been
posted in several western states where a historic
drought is threatening a catastrophic fire
season.
CBS This Morning: Lake Mead, the nation s
largest reservoir, is on track to soon hit
its lowest level ever recorded.
ABC15 Arizona:
For the first time ever, the federal government
is preparing to declare a drought-emergency
on the lower Colorado River.
POSTEL: It is the lifeline for the American
Southwest, supplies water to about 5 million
acres of cropland 40 million people get drinking
water from the Colorado, it's shared by two
countries, so it is a binational river, the
US and Mexico. But it hasn't been managed
in a way that really meets the needs of all
of the stakeholders in the basin. And when
the river was divvied up in 1922, you know,
we were coming off of an unusually wet period.
And so the thinking was, there's more water
in the river, than it turns out that it naturally
carried even excluding climate issues.
SIERRA: The Colorado River Compact of 1922
was essential for the development of the West.
It was built to meet the needs of the time,
to get as much water as possible to the region
s growing cities and farmlands. But it didn
t anticipate climate change or even the notion
of scarcity. The pact guarantees amounts of
water to states, rather than percentages.
So, for example, today the pact entitles California
to 4.4 million acre feet of water per year,
that s well over a trillion gallons. Colorado
gets 3.8 million acre feet, and so on. Millions
of people in these and other states have built
their lives around these amounts. Farms, cities,
sewage systems, hydroelectric plants, every
fountain in Las Vegas, every golf course on
the California coast. Every home for 40 million
people. Meanwhile, climate change means that
there is less snowfall in the Rockies, less
water going into the river, and less water
available to the members of the pact. But
every year, each of those 40 million people
expect the same amount.
POSTEL: Plus, and this is an important point
going forward, when the water was divvied
up in 1922 there were three important stakeholders
not at the table. One was Mexico, even though
the last 100 miles of the river is in Mexico,
and the delta is in Mexico, and it flows into
the sea in Mexico, Mexico wasn't there. The
Native American tribes that have lived with
the river in the watershed alongside the river
for generations and generations and generations
and have legally senior rights to the river,
they were not at the table, they have not
been able to exercise those rights. And third,
the river was not represented at the table.
And so the river has had no say.
SIERRA: This idea, called environmental personhood
, suggests that natural entities like lakes
and rivers should have the legal right to
resist alteration in a court of law. The idea
turns Western notions of property rights on
their head, and it's certainly controversial.
Still, it has growing momentum around the
world, with indigenous communities leading
the charge. Advocates say it s one of the
best ways to protect threatened waterways
and other natural features. Different versions
of the status have been adopted in countries
like Bangladesh and New Zealand, and even
in the U.S. state of Ohio, along the shores
of Lake Eerie.
POSTEL: And so those three omissions immediately
created a problem on top of giving the seven
states in the US more water than the river
usually carries. So it was a problem from
the beginning. And so now we're trying to
go back and fix this. But it's really tough,
because we're already in a mega drought, there's
way less water than there's been throughout
this history. And yet, we're also trying to
correct the omissions around that table in
1922. The complication is even more because
you have an upper basin and a lower basin,
and the upper basin, by law of the river is
supposed to provide a set amount of water
to the lower basin, well, that's getting,
you know, more complicated and the lower basin
is where you have more of the demand. That's
where most of the irrigated agriculture is,
that's where Tucson and Phoenix and Los Angeles
are. And so what's happening is as Lake Mead,
the biggest reservoir, along with Lake Powell,
they're the two biggest reservoirs in the
country, as those levels go down, they're
approaching a point, and this may happen this
year, where, by the rules of the river right
now, there'll be an enforced reduction in
allocation of water to Arizona and to Nevada.
If the lake goes below 1075 feet above mean
sea level, there has to be that reduction.
And I think that may happen this year. And
so that'll be the first time that these agreed
upon rules kick in, and we'll see what happens.
But, to their credit, the states really have
worked together to develop what they're calling
drought contingency plans. You know, this
drought is long term, we don't know when it's
gonna end. And so Arizona, California, and
Nevada have purposely tried to keep more water
in Lake Mead to avoid getting to that lower
level where, you know, the regulations of
the federal government will kick in. And so
that's cooperation. And that's good. That's
saying we're in this together. But it's still
complicated, and they're already working on
the next round of these rules. So the cooperation
is there, the ability to really solve the
problems long term, you know, we'll see.
SIERRA: The pact is still a long way from
comprehensively addressing the West s water
problem, but there is reason for hope. The
agreement has evolved, Mexico gained its missing
seat at the table in 1944, and several smaller
amendments over the years have created stipulations
to improve conservation and sharing during
drought conditions. The capacity for compromise
has been demonstrated, but there is going
to need to be a lot more before the river
becomes sustainable.
SIERRA: What does the Colorado River tell
us about the problems that we're gonna face
and the changes that we're going to have to
get used to as conditions get worse?
POSTEL: I think the Colorado River reminds
us that that water is life. We depend on rivers
for so many things. You know, we built these
dams on the river for important purposes to
generate electricity to control flooding,
to store water, so we can provide that winter
flood water and snowmelt runoff to farmers
in the summer. So we can provide drinking
water to all of these desert cities that have
sprung up so they're serving very important
purposes. And so the river is really being
asked to do a tremendous amount of work. You're
in a situation of over allocation and increasing
drought and aridification. But we all depend
on that river and there's just so much it
can give without, you know, kind of dying
out itself.
SIERRA: I mean, it sounds like we all need
to get used to a lot more water compromise.
POSTEL: We do need to get used to more water
compromise and also, you know, we're in a
different moment of time than we were when
we developed the water rights and the laws
and the engineering infrastructure that went
in decades ago. We're in a different moment
in time. We have more people, we have more
demand, we have the big concerns about climate
change. We have recurring droughts, we have
recurring floods. So in some ways, you know,
we need to adapt.
SIERRA: And the Western United States isn
t alone. The same conflicts are playing out
over rivers, lakes and ground sources across
the world. And in each place you find the
same themes: dwindling supply, overallocation,
and institutions that were not built with
the flexibility that climate change requires.
POSTEL: You know, even though there's a treaty
between India and Pakistan over the Indus
River, we've seen a lot of, you know, conflict
around water related issues in Kashmir, for
example, even though there's a treaty that
sets out how that water should be shared between
India and Pakistan, we've seen in in Africa,
a lot of tension and violence, even over water
between different ethnic groups, because there's
not sufficient water there to meet the needs
of everyone in the in the culture and in the
form of agriculture in particular that they've
been accustomed to.
SIERRA: One of the most talked-about cases
of water scarcity is Capetown, South Africa,
which in 2017 came within a hair s breadth
of becoming the first major city to run out
of water completely. Preparing for the worst,
Capetown s day zero plans included shutting
off pipes, and deploying resources to deal
with social unrest and outbreaks of disease.
Strong rains staved off the emergency in 2018,
but water anxiety remains a serious problem
in South Africa and in many other parts of
the Continent too.
POSTEL: And so, again, it takes many forms.
And for example, the Nile basin, you know,
84% of the water is coming from Ethiopia.
But Egypt is, from a geopolitical and military
sense, the most powerful. And so that's where
you could run into trouble, because the upstream
country has, in a sense, the hydrologic power,
but not the military power. You look at all
the rivers that come out of China, well, China
has the military power and the hydrologic
power, so you're not necessarily going to
see a war there. But the downstream countries
are potentially at risk of water shortage
of not having the security of water that they
need because of decisions made upstream. And
so you have to look at the dynamic from both
the geopolitical sense and from the hydrologic
side.
SIERRA: Water scarcity is local, but it doesn
t always stay local. In a world where we import
so many things, water problems in one place
can easily trickle over to another.
GIORDAN: When people talk about water and
conflict or water and politics, they're often
thinking about the direct issues or the direct
outcomes in some place. But there's so much
trade in agriculture now and many countries
are very dependent on agricultural imports
that a water problem in one place can transfer
to another place via the trade. If people
cannot afford food, they are not going to
be happy and you can expect food price rises
to be associated with political instability,
particularly in places where people spend
a lot of their income on food. And so, that
s a mechanism where a drought in one country
can affect another.
SIERRA: Cross-border water inequalities can
lead to tension. For decades, movies like
Mad Max have portrayed water wars as the endgame
of environmental degradation.
MadMax: Fury Road: Do not my friends, become
addicted to water, it will take hold of you
and you will resent its absence
SIERRA: Do you think that there's potential
for conflict over water, as you know, scarcity
and overconsumption continue?
POSTEL: There definitely is potential for
conflict over access to water. We've already
seen this historically, we can see conflict
between countries, we can see conflict within
countries, we can see conflict between cities
and farms, we can see conflict between different
ethnic groups. And we have seen this and I
think we do need to be aware that this could
worsen over time. And I particularly worry
about the effect of food prices and rising
food prices in particular on that social and
political stability. We need to really be
on the alert for these kinds of social and
political events and really work to prevent
that rise in civil unrest from getting out
of hand.
SIERRA: But not everyone believes water conflict
is inevitable, or even the most important
part of the story.
GIORDANO: The premise of the water war concept
is water supplies are fixed, that global populations
are rising and in addition to that, as populations
are getting wealthier, they're consuming more
meat and, if you're gonna grow beef or pork
or chicken, you know, you have to feed multiple
kilos of that grain to that meat. So meat
consumption per capita is rising and the number
of people is rising and the water is fixed
and so people extrapolated that to say, well,
at some point, because water is so precious,
countries are going to fight over it.
GIORDANO: But the real story of water at the
international level has been one of cooperation,
not one of outright conflict. As you go down
in scale, that's where you're more likely
to find actual conflict and in particular
violent conflict and you can find hundreds
of examples of two farmers shot each other.
You're gonna be hard pressed to find an example
of of two countries. So, what I would say
connects also to the trade issue we talked
about, within countries, poor water management
coupled with a drought, coupled with other
pressures can lead to conflicts, can be a
factor in conflicts within a state. Sometimes
those conflicts can spill over. People discuss
that, especially with Middle Eastern states
and some Sahalian states in Africa now.
SIERRA: Conflict over water, whether between
two farmers, two cities, or even, in the worst-case
scenario, two nations, becomes likelier as
supply dries up. But there are solutions out
there. There is enough water to meet the needs
of a growing global population, but there
is not enough water to continue all of the
habits we developed before climate change.
In order to create sustainability, we are
going to have to compromise, as individuals
and as societies. And we are going to have
to build institutions that have compromise
and flexibility at their core.
POSTEL: With better policies and incentives,
I think we can have, you know, happy, healthy,
productive lives, while consuming less water.
You know, I don't need to eat red meat every
day. If we look at our diets, you know, the
amount of water that goes into producing the
hamburger is way more than goes into producing
a delicious non meat meal. And so even if
we reduce our meat consumption by half, say
that's going to save water, you're not using
all of that irrigation water to grow alfalfa
to feed to the cows, or to grow corn to feed
to the cows. And so we have a lot of ability
to adjust. I think we need to do it in an
equitable way, I think we need to do it in
a way that gives people important choice.
You know, diet is a very personal thing, I
don't think we should be prescriptive about
it, but to provide the information and let
people know, hey, you know, some of this is
in our control. Some of this is in our hands.
And we've also only begun to tap the potential
of conservation and increased efficiency of
water use. We're saving because of more efficient
toilets and faucets and showerheads, and dishwashers
and washing machines, were saving 9 billion
gallons of water a day, that's equivalent
to nine New York City's worth of water because
of more efficient appliances and fixtures
in our homes. That's really huge. And we haven't
begun to tap the potential in irrigated agriculture,
more efficient delivery of water, more efficient
application of water, the ability to put sensors
in the soil to know how much water is really
needed to grow the crops, we can marry information
technology to efficiency technology and get
more crop per drop across the board. So there's
a lot we can do to solve these problems, it's
not a doomsday scenario, we just need to develop
the political will, the social will to make
these changes and they can be made. My concern
is that the problems are unfolding, the challenges
are unfolding much faster than these solutions.
Everywhere I look around the world where there
is a problem related to breaking the water
cycle, there is an example of how to fix it
in the real world. We just need to scale these
solutions up.
GIORDANO: A big part is developing the understanding
that there are other people using this water
and so communication and awareness is a big
part of the institution building process.
And I would say on the negative side, we haven't
done that very well so far. On the positive
side, institutions take a long time to build
and trust takes a long time to build, and
we're moving in a path in the right direction,
but these processes take time. So I always
say, short-term, I'm a pessimist and, and
long-term, I'm an optimist.
GIORDANO: I think the only thing I'd say is
water, just to get everybody to step back
and think about how they feel about water.
And when I say feel, I actually mean really
feel, like, you know, there's a reason that
you want the hotel room with the sea view
and there's a reason people wanna sit by the
river. There's something about water that
is special to us. You'll be hard placed to
find any religion that doesn't have water
as part of its origin story of, of humankind
or, or the universe. It has a special place
for us. It has a special impact on us in a
way that few other things do. And I think
if we stop and think about that for a while,
how important it is to all of us in every
aspect of our life, that maybe we can think
a little bit more clearly about coming up
with good solutions.
SIERRA: Can you paint me a picture, what's
at stake, if we don't learn to cooperate and
conserve better?
POSTEL: We're looking at a world that will
be less good for us to live in. We will not
have the healthy rivers and riverside forests
and fish and wildlife that we want to have
in our world, they will be gone. And then
secondly, you know, we'll see more conflict
because water is life, water is essential
to food, water is essential for drinking.
And as we see, as things become scarce, they
also grow more inequitable, so of course,
the wealthy are going to get what they need,
and the poor will not get what they need.
And so there'll be more inequity, which breeds
more tension, which breeds more violence.
And so we'll have a less peaceful world as
well as a less healthy world. And that's not
a world that most of us want to live in.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes. Have a
question or some feedback? Just feel like
saying hey? Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you are a fan of the show, we d love
if you could leave us a review. Ideally a
good one, with five stars. It really does
help us get noticed. Why It Matters is a production
of the Council on Foreign Relations. The show
is created and produced by Asher Ross, Jeremy
Sherlick, and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound
designer is Markus Zakaria. Rafaela Siewert
is our assistant podcast producer. Sophie
Yass is our summer intern. Robert McMahon
is our Managing Editor, and Doug Halsey is
our Chief Digital Officer. Extra help for
this episode was provided by Claire Felter
and Kali Robinson. Original music is composed
by Ceiri Torjussen. Special thanks go to Richard
Haass and Jeff Reinke. For Why It Matters
this is Gabrielle Sierra signing off. See
you soon!